FAILURES, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
WHEN I'M WATCHING THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS OR CERTAIN 2020
CANDIDATES OR THEIR MEDIA CHUMS,
I FEEL LIKE I'M WATCHING
CHARACTERS IN A CARTOON SERIES
INSTEAD OF REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE PEOPLE.
MONTH AFTER MONTH, THEY JUST
BOLDLY PREDICT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
POLITICAL DEMISE.
IF THEY GIVE AMERICANS THE
IMPRESSION THAT THEY HAVE HIM
TRAPPED, THAT HE'S HEADED OFF
THE EDGE OF THE CLIFF, WELL
TONIGHT, WE FOCUS ON FIVE WAYS
THAT TRUMP HAS OUTSMARTED THEM
ALL.
FIRST, THEIR RELENTLESS TRASHING
OF HIS ECONOMIC RECORD.
>> IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
RECESSION, IT'S GOING TO BE A
SMORGASBORD.
>> FEARS OF A GLOBAL RECESSION,
THE R WORD TO.
>> IT'S NEAR PANIC TERRITORY.
>> HE COULD BE SEEKING
REELECTION DURING A RECESSION.
>> THE MARKET HAS NOWHERE TO GO
BUT DOWN COME OUT RECESSION IS
WRITTEN ALL OVER THE FOREHEAD OF
THIS ECONOMY.
>> Laura: THAT WAS ALL BUNK,
THE R WORD THAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE NOW WORRIED ABOUT THAT THEY
HAVE TO CONFRONT HIS RECORD AS
IN RECORD-BREAKING STOCK MARKET
AGAIN TODAY.
INCREDIBLY LOW UNEMPLOYMENT,
ALSO RECORD NUMBERS THERE.
ECONOMISTS AND BLOOMBERG
COLUMNIST MICHAEL STRAHAN WRITES
TODAY THIS YEAR THE RATE OF
EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE AGE 25-54
HAS FINALLY RECOVERED FROM THE
GREAT RECESSION AND HERE IS YET
ANOTHER REASON TO BE GRATEFUL,
THE ECONOMY IN 2020 IS SAID TO
HAVE A BETTER YEAR -- WHAT
HAPPENED TO RECESSION?
HOW DO THESE PEOPLE STILL HAVE
JOBS?
SECOND, THERE ARE REPORTS THAT
TRUMP'S G.O.P. WALL OF SUPPORT
WAS SOMEHOW CRACKING, SURE TO BE
HIS UNDOING.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ASKS OR PRESSES
THE LEADER OF A FOREIGN COUNTRY
TO CARRY OUT AN INVESTIGATION OF
A POLITICAL NATURE, THAT'S
TROUBLING.
AND I FEEL THAT.
>> THERE'S GOT TO BE SOMEBODY IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO WOULD
STAND UP AND SAY WE BELIEVE IN
THE RULE OF LAW.
ONCE THAT HAPPENED, THE
FLOODGATES CAN OPEN.
>> THERE'S A CHANCE OF THERE
WILL BE 20 REPUBLICANS, I
WOULDN'T BET ON IT BUT I THINK
THERE'S A CHANCE.
>> Laura: THERE'S A CHANCE
THAT YOU'RE WRONG AGAIN.
TODAY, TRUMP ENJOYS 90% APPROVAL
AMONG REPUBLICANS.
HAS ANYONE CHECKED ON BILL WELD
LATELY?
THIRD, DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA
WARNED THAT TRUMP'S TARIFFS
AGAINST CHINA WOULD PROVE
DISASTROUS.
>> HIS TRADE WAR WITH CHINA IS
TANKING THE U.S. ECONOMY.
>> THIS TRADE WAR IS TANKING THE
ECONOMY.
>> IF THE TRADE WAR WERE TO GET
WORSE, IT COULD TANK THE WHOLE
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
>> Laura: TODAY GET UP IN THE
MORNING AND PICK UP
MORNING AND PICK AP
MORNING AND PICK A FEW KEYWORDS?
ANOTHER SWING AND A MESS, OUR
ECONOMY IS BOOMING WHILE CHINA'S
GDP IS GROWING AT ITS SLOWEST
PACE SINCE THE 1990s.
IT IS EXPECTED TO CONTRACT
FURTHER NEXT YEAR.
FOURTH, DEMOCRATS BELIEVE
TRUMP'S SUMMERTIME WAR OF WORDS
WITH YIELD POLITICAL PAIN FOR
BOTH HIM AND HIS PARTY.
>> I AM NOT SURPRISED WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAID THAT FOUR SITTING
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS SHOULD GO
BACK TO THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
HE WOULD LOVE NOTHING MORE THAN
TO DIVIDE OUR COUNTRY, THIS IS A
DISRUPTION AND A DISTRACTION.
FROM THE CALLOUS, CHAOTIC, AND
CORRUPT CULTURE OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> THE SORT OF RHETORIC HAS A
CONSEQUENCE FOR HIM, THIS COULD
HURT HIM IN 2020.
>> Laura: I'M NOT SURE WHO
THAT IS BUT THE REALITY IS
TRUMPS DECISION TO TAKE ON THE
HIT GIRLS MIGHT HAVE MADE THE
MOMENTARY VICTIMS BUT IT ALSO
MEANT NANCY PELOSI HAD TO COME
TO THEIR DEFENSE.
>> WE JUST HAD A MEETING TO
CLEAR THE AIR, IN A FAMILY, YOU
HAVE YOUR DIFFERENCES BUT YOU
ARE STILL FAMILY.
>> Laura: THIS ONLY GAVE THEM
MORE PROMINENCE AND WITH THE
HELP OF THE FAUX WHISTLE-BLOWER,
WE ARE BROUGHT TO NUMBER 5, THE
SQUAD'S IMPEACHMENT FANTASY
BECAME A DAILY REALITY.
>> THIS WAS ANOTHER BOMBSHELL
TODAY JUST LIKE THERE WAS A
BOMBSHELL ON WEDNESDAY.
>> DEVASTATING TESTIMONY
CORROBORATING EVIDENCE OF
BRIBERY, THE PRESIDENT ABUSED
POWER AND VIOLATED HIS OATH.
>> Laura: WHEN THE HEARINGS
ENDED UP SWINGING PUBLIC OPINION
AGAINST DEMOCRATS IMPEACHMENT
FANTASY, THE LEFT MOVED ON TO
THEIR NEXT DELUSION.
A FEDERAL JUDGE NOMINATED BY
OBAMA IS FORCING TRUMP'S FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL TO TURN
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT TO TESTIF
TESTIFY.
THE MEDIA WAS BREATHLESS WITH
EXCITEMENT.
>> A FEDERAL JUDGE RULING THE
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DON
MCGANN MUST COOPERATE WITH THE
IMPEACHMENT INVESTIGATION, THIS
IS A HUGE WIN FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> THIS CHANGES THE DYNAMICS OF
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: NEVER MIND THE FACT
EVEN IF COMPELLED TO SHOW UP,
DON MCGANN CAN WAVE OFF EVERY
QUESTION IS PRIVILEGED.
ONCE AGAIN THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD
TRUMP'S NUMBER BUT IN FACT HE
REALLY HAD THEIRS.
IF THE SPEAKER DOESN'T WATCH
OUT, HER NEW NICKNAME WILL BE
WILEY PELOSI.
[CARTOON SOUND EFFECTS]
>> Laura: WILEY PELOSI, WITH A
MAGNET?
IT'S PERFECT.
NO MATTER WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
THROW AT TRUMP, THEY CAN'T TAKE
HIM DOWN, IT'S DRIVING THEM
CRAZY.
THEIR PREDICTIONS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S STAYING POWER HAVE
BEEN SPECTACULAR FLOPS.
HERE ARE A FEW PREDICTIONS FROM
YOURS TRULY.
THE PRESIDENT WILL GET NOMINATED
WITH OVERWHELMING SUPPORT FROM
HIS PARTY AND INDEPENDENCE WHILE
DEMOCRATS NOMINATE SOMEONE WITH
ALMOST ZERO ABILITY TO CONNECT
WITH AMERICANS OUTSIDE OF MAJOR
CITIES.
DESPITE THEIR SERIES OF